are we bringing him up okay sorry
um michael b jordan has stated that he
is starting and only fans
and his only fans content is not going
to be nudes it's going to be
photos and videos of his beard and
mustache and he's eating stuff
and like [ __ ] gets in it sounds [ __ ]
terrible and all of the proceeds will go
to a barber school um this sounds like a
horrible idea
hey you know he's dating your girl
who's not laurie harvey let's not listen
that's it he brought her to thanksgiving
ah
well here's the thing he's all up on
them titties
wait what does she look like again
listen you don't win sex man of the year
and not have a dime like that
well that would hurt now she has a
history with some let's see who's she
every future uh trey songz daddy diddy p
diddy's son
malik and now she goes to michael b
jordan because she wants wholesome
you know what i'm saying he's a child
actor he's not you know he's not
dangerous like
no he ain't a bad boy yeah no he's
wholesome he just plays one on tv
i tell you what's not wholesome okay and
they had to kill him on the wire
he deserved it god damn she got sitting
here she got oh
look at her future had her the best he
had her dressing nice
look i'm a future fan yeah future pull
some hoes bro his catalog
give it a chance
that's the story was that the story
that's my story
damn she's thick that's her mama is she
bodied up to him she's brought it up
she brought it up right right yeah you
are right yeah yeah
that's how you know you in like a
different kind of class if lori harvey
you start dating laura harvey
who made it like congratulations he had
to get sexy as man feel like she made it
they'll probably get married no no she's
the skill does she have obj she look at
her history you dated obj she
did everyone oh damn how old is she
she's 24 6
like 23 i think she's only 23 she's in
her prime and that's her oh my god
you're about
23. she's only six years older than me
and she's
she's dated all these people already yep
look at her thanksgiving together yeah
are you kidding me yes bro
i'm on my i'm on my way just come on how
about futures
line up future has a crazy life
baby mama blac chyna blac chyna okay she
got him tatted on her
yeah and then the same day he tweeted
that he's single he's single yeah that's
my stuff
like yep she does justin yeah that's
what she did that's trey songz we forgot
about trey
i said trey earlier yeah trey's a good
looking dude oh
my boy that's a guy right there what's
in that night what's happening
with hamilton jay follow him well you're
crazy he's the richest one she's dated
mm-hmm
who's who is that guy memphis some guy
named memphis
is he a writer memphis rapper football
oh no he's a
uh premier league player oh there you go
hey look at her list though look at her
list yeah
she's a catalog you're right she has a
cat thank you bro wow how can she not
that's insane i'm next malik's next
couple more episodes baby
[Laughter]
oh gosh that's hilarious what else you
got jen
okay so this was sent in by ryan walsh i
believe we talked about this guy before
he's a bodybuilder from kazakhstan we've
talked about him before yeah
who is in a relationship with a sex doll
and
his whole backstory is that he met her
at a club and he defended her from other
men
trying to hit on her and when he finally
posted her on instagram she got insecure
about her look so he took her to a
plastic surgeon
where she got plastic surgery and she's
now working at a
as a waitress he just proposed a few
weeks ago
and now they are married she said yes
that boy is mentally ill
i like her in the missy elliott you're
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
look at them in a bathtub with a
[ __ ] toy just wait uh
he's bought it up why is he what uh i
don't know why is he normal
he's trying to make some people do this
just to make like headlines yeah nah
i mean what girl like [ __ ] tired i
see nipples let me see
they have some plastic nipples so i
think we can show this they look pretty
good
[Music]
does that mean can you imagine being the
photographer who took these
oh yeah hold on all right
dude you sure you want to do this oh
yeah
he's back he got his body though he's a
good looking dude what is he doing
he's hairy too
commercial i'm fine already well you got
to do well you're dating a doll homeboy
we got it i don't trust dudes with
nipple rings yeah no never oh he has
long nipples too
you got the dog you know she's mentally
ill yeah
he does have big necks
look at that do you get a nose job or
something
scroll back hey guys i feel better i
made my nose
and teeth i made my nose and teeth i
want to thank you for your support i
appreciate your support
send you my hugs and hot kisses
disgusting
and he's got a lot of followers 40 000
something nope
i think well i think it's 47 000. yeah
he's ill
and that's the type of guys that busy
stuff what is that that boy lost
who's this guy oh he's a gay man home
video
of a joke this is a home video for a
joke song with my friends
oh uh he must be uh i'm a big boy
i mean yeah he did wait is that a girl
that's a dude no i mean that's so i mean
dude if you're gay that's fine
you don't need to marry a doll to hide
it why is he dressed like his daughter
oh that boy cheeked up girl
get that boy a bike oh boy thick
that boy built like a black widow just
big ass
anyways big legs
he's got to be gay then right 100 i
don't wipe that might when i get a male
1 oh my god he dressed like rakishi
yeah he's into like freaky things uh
yeah yeah man uh okay we can get off his
page now yeah
this one or the other one yeah no that
one this dude's living his best life
yeah you got to shave that [ __ ] yeah
he's he's quiet
he's a bodybuilder that's how my quads
gonna be in a couple of weeks i
guarantee
good for him man do your thing congrats
on the marriage
yeah to the happy couple yeah shout out
that's so sh i mean good
dudes obviously you got some issues
going on love is tight whatever way
shape or form yeah whatever yeah uh
oh [ __ ] that reminds me
[Music]
i know all right yeah so these are from
carlos de la garza he's a grammy
award-winning engineer producer he's my
mentor he's one that taught me how to do
engineering these are signature sticks i
want to see if you can actually play
something remember you said you could do
something exactly
go for it why are you following go ahead
blam you know i like how i like how
the people just like you know all right
what you want me to play anything
remember you said you could play yeah
but this way you're holding them already
like oh [ __ ] you know what's up bro
y'all really don't believe me bro but
alright it's okay what huh i'll be
playing it man let me see
it's been a long time it's been a while
all right
[Music]
you lied the way he's holding him though
he's messing around he knows how to play
he does not
really see i don't know i don't know the
technique of holding it uh
you know but um you know
i i could probably do a little something
do a little something let's see i don't
know if i can hold it
i got you all right
[Music]
you actually held it right like this too
yeah hold on
[Music]
like there's that show born this way
where it's people with down syndrome and
it's them trying to fit in the real
world and like get their [ __ ] together
and the i think there's three seasons or
something like that so the first season
you're like into it it's like it's like
real like sweet
but then it kind of gets dark yeah sad
because
it shows their limitations yes and you
realize
oh they can't have a normal life because
they have down syndrome
another girl gets with another down
syndrome dude and they they get married
but then they want kids so then the
parents have to sit them down and
explain to them why they can't have kids
it's so heavy yeah that's his hair it's
like right
up here that's the kind of show with the
uk version where they kind of sit down
they're like you may never
find love yeah like that's such a bummer
no
you're the downstairs one like they and
they want to go be on their own
like they don't want to be with their
parents they want their independence
they want to drive they want
that yeah still have that innate like
instinct to want to like
be on their like you know what i mean
like yeah it's just
and there are people of completely
able-bodied in mind
who don't have that do you know what i
mean yeah they still live with their
parents
yeah yeah and that's why they don't give
a [ __ ] it's wild that that can exist
in a person who is quote unquote
mentally challenged
yeah when it doesn't you know it doesn't
exist in a completely abled person like
i wonder what that is
it's explain to the audience that's
listening about like you said something
earlier
that uh two people who have down
syndrome can have kids explain that to
them well because their kids are gonna
have down syndrome oh yeah that's what
yeah
and so they and they get you're
technically not allowed like if they
can't
two the first one was like the first one
was
oh damn you use your camera to find your
glasses what app is that
i think he genuinely does it and josh is
so nice
you just open up your camera and
[Laughter]
i'm like now with uh down syndrome
community
wow it's malach on a spectrum